to see Eric is professor in Carnegie
Mellon University he has done lots of
work spending many areas machine
learning including developing
statistical machine learning methods and
algorithms and also Lots application in
social networks implementation of
biology and even computer vision in
natural language processing
he recently is also pushing this
direction of combining machinery with a
large-scale system architecture and he's
going to talk more about his lecture in
this direction
all right oh it's such a great pleasure
to be back in Berkeley especially I saw
my old advisor professor Karp in the sea
it's truly a great honor to have him
here and I saw my kind of store
yesterday so it's a very good evening
you know after so many years yeah I'm
going to talk about some of my recent
work in a so-called system and a quiz
neko design I heard of your talks this
morning already
this one will be a little bit different
in terms of the flavor and a style okay
I'm going to also present a few theorems
but without proof I'm going to more
focusing on presenting the open problems
that we are facing you know in designing
efficient deployable machine learning
algorithms so this is perhaps a way
sorry okay this is a way many people see
machine learning maybe you guys will be
laughing at it but people do see machine
learning like this they want the machine
learning algorithm to be a black box
that you throw in data and that you get
the answer out of it which is kind of
naive but if we look at ourselves and
how we see computer is no different from
here right we are programming you know a
black box right in Agins and we wish the
box to do what it's supposed to do
without any error and then we can
analyze our agrees and in terms of its
convergence
bounds and all that with no worry about
whether the machine goes wrong all right
why in many other theorem you don't see
any coefficients talking about the
machine behavior and that's actually not
necessarily you know the ideal situation
you are going to face in industry so
here I have been working industry for a
while and I have a start-up and our goal
is to offer machine learning solutions
to big data users and typically after
you have data and you are assigned the
task and given a hammer you need to
figure out this whole thing in the
middle which includes egg with a model
implantation system architects and so
forth and the kind of solutions that we
are having now is really a handcrafted
monolithic kind of well off solution you
know one for each particular problem
maybe the same problem sub by different
people would be also different therefore
many of the results are not repeatable
so it's a actually a big barrier right
now causing machinery in AI not to be
very popular in you know the greater
industry and this is actually well not
the personal kind of experience I had
before in a way many years ago developed
a pretty good algorithm for social
network embedding which were able to in
fact embed a 1 million node network
using a single machine in like a few
minutes so it's a pretty amazing you
know we publish kind of your papers on
this topic but then you know we want to
bring this egg version to a face book
and the kind of problems they give is
this much big let's say what meaning is
pretty good but after all my network is
building maybe you should demonstrate
your egg with a tenth of that which is a
hundred meaning ok and of course they
are going to offer you not one machine
but maybe a cluster of a thousand
machines well if you are naive and say
well let's use Hadoop and deploy these
Edwards and once on the machine maybe I
should see 0.6 minute kind of completion
because my resource grow a thousand time
by problem grow a hundred time right but
a choice is that if you really write it
as we did it doesn't finish in more than
a week
so why that's the case that means the
system is not ideal there are something
going on in the system which is beyond
what egg wisdom can handle so that's why
I want to take another look of this
problem which
often solved in machine learning and see
how really to grant these about
solutions on a real computational
infrastructure right so here is a
typical machine setup you are doing a
optimization problem where you setup the
last function which is your model you
specify your parameters you may also
introduce some regular risers to control
the capacity or may be introduced prior
knowledge ease this is the part of maybe
95% of machine learning the other 5%
maybe goes to the egg Wiz and we come up
with you know work typically not a
closed-form algorithm but a iterative
convergent egg wisdom you know finding a
fixed point and iterate using some
update equations so this one is the holy
grail of that egg we need to figure out
whether this one is a gradient a
projected gradient or a smoothest
version of that or other you know
second-order terms and so forth and then
you're going to do this integration
hopefully without any trouble but in
modern days this particular operation is
going to be under severe challenge why
because in many industry problems we are
really facing either very big data a big
model which lets you to face the
scenario maybe you are going to you know
every time you know update a gigantic
vector of matrix of parameters which
could be having 100 million parameters
which is not often not not unusual in
deep learning for example these days or
even a high dimensional regression
problem or if you really are working on
huge data then this one also will Expo
and therefore you are going to swipe you
know a terabyte of data maybe in every
iteration that's also very very
difficult and you consider doing this
you know for indefinite number of
iterations is something quite
challenging because in that case you
know you probably need to think about
solving the problem on one machine but
are many machines in the distributed
environment and then how to let all
these machines behave as if they are a
single machine is actually a pretty
serious and difficult technical problem
it's not only an engineering problem a
programmer assigned to this job you're
they cannot figure out how to do it if
they don't know enough machine learning
exactly when how to do
right and you know people try it
solving these problems you know using
Hadoop for example or using spark very
often not you know having a lot of
success and I'm going to say a few words
about why that's the case
okay so here is maybe a more people
booked into that so how do we paralyze a
program if you have multiple machines
well basically this particular step
which is the consequence of maybe a long
effort of a machine learning theoretical
study where eventually leads to some
kind of update procedure that you need
to now cannot bring them into a parallel
version and the full mathematician I
think the gradients that kind of need to
way need to address is to make these two
things equivalent so that that
mathematically give you the same answer
and then one of the thing we come up
with is to make them synchronize able so
that you know when each machine are
doing their job or have done their job
they should shake hands and exchange
their notes so that we make sure
everything go okay then go to the next
iteration well this is actually in
practice a very expensive step even
though in our analysis of the equity we
don't see that we already assumed that
the synchronization takes zero cost and
also the synchronization should not have
any faulty operation and also the
message can actually be transmitted
across the internet or the ethernet so
that you don't rain to network
congestion and so forth none of this
actual actually in a big digital system
therefore you know for a real
distributed environment you either do
this kind of synchronization like what
Hadoop will automatically offer to do
for you and you'll pay a huge cost in
you know basically a latency and ending
in communication and overhead or if you
just remove the synchronization you are
likely to break these equivalence and
right into a divergent algorithm that's
politically happened you know in many
other plantations and that brands to
basically no a maybe a renewed effort in
asking how to analyze efficiency in a
practical equation that is a really
deployed in the field and doing this
combat right so if you look at these
typical bound that
we often see in our AG Visnjic analysis
you know which gives you a rate of
convergence in the order of iterations
and first of this particular and as it
doesn't help you how much iteration will
cost and also there isn't a coefficient
telling you the status of the machine
and other systems but in reality there
are a lot of subtleties I just want to
point maybe even one you'll probably see
many papers especially nowadays this
deep learning papers which almost forced
you to use the a multi core or multi
machine for me because it's so big then
very very interestingly the reported
improve performance on a cluster or a
multi-core system is typically in the
form of a throughput support means that
the amount of data you can process per
unit amount of time and as a result if
you have more machines your throughput
will grow literally very very happy
results what is not often shown in a
real experiment is this curve which is
that the number of iterations it takes
to converge okay because if you do a
lousy job in or in synchronization where
you add more and more machines
mathematically the quality of each
iteration is segregating because they
are going to be less and less
synchronized that going to do it in
tourism one more error therefore the
effectiveness the mathematical progress
or statistic aim of every iteration
could be very worse therefore this is
experiment weighted actually with some
cluster setup you can see that as you
had one machine that number here is a
takes to converge to the optimum spot is
going to be bigger but ideally what you
want is this when you change your
machines you are going to experience the
same number of iterations and then you
have a bigger throughput and then we'll
multiply these together you'll get a
faster convergence in the world clock
sense not in terms of number of
iterations right so how to achieve that
point well this is a slide I'm going to
steep I meant to say that to achieve
this it is not enough just to design a
smarter algorithm or reengineer the
system because very often our machining
evidence has very interesting
mathematical behaviors which may offer
different opportunities than other stand
competitions such as a database
operation query augmentation and so
forth and also you know by knowing the
details in some of the systems sometimes
the algorithm can be redesigned or
optimized so that you can leverage on
bidirectionally the opportunities out
there and this is in contrast with many
of the traditional system work or
academic work which is a really
transaction centric and we want to
maintain the algorithm to be
transactional a rigorous and therefore
automatic crack knees of their cuisine
is the key of the operation in machine
learning after we're solving a fashion
problem right mathematically your goal
is to go to the top of this hill whether
you go this route that road you make a
mistake in the middle may be less
relevant if you still know the hollow
direction so that's why I think there is
a opportunity there to restart a system
design one of the way people do this
exercise is like this to create a super
you know specialized and the complicated
thing which can work on one problem but
if you ask this guy to do another job
say hunting in the forest maybe this guy
will run into trouble right so what is
really needed is to you know ask whether
such a system and with mokou design can
needs to even a generic solution which
support not only one everything about
many many different problems and many
equations so I'm going to share with you
some of the work took place in my group
and also with my colleagues at CMU in
these are four dimensions how to develop
a general-purpose architecture for the
assistant understands even code design
to solve this particular step more
effectively on the digital environment
so I'm going to begin with something
very simple so the first thing people
ask when you have a distributed system
is to decide on what to distribute right
so for example here I have a scenario
where the data can be very big I have
another scenario where the parameter may
be very big or maybe below that big then
in fact the problem even started from
here when you divide the data to
different machines and when you divide
the model to different machines the time
prophets that is take a loss or the type
of care you need to bring in to make
sure things are not going wrong it's
going to be different so let's quickly
take a look up how to divide this say
many of the distributed implementations
of a logical equation the first income
in mind is to do load balancing right
load balancing in this particular case
means the following say I do a large
very large regression problem and say
this particular regression law vector is
1 billion dimensional what will ask me
where I get this problem where this
problem is solved in Google almost every
second so it is actually a very real
problem even though mathematically we
can ask well regressing on a 1 billion
dimensional kind of problem seems to
need infinite data and so forth but
that's actually you know a different
discussion we can have because most of
these problems will have regulations
therefore they are still in practical
value you know in having a convergent
evolution but engineering wise how to
solve this you know using a computer
cluster it's actually quite interesting
you can imagine that maybe when you do
the following we need to know divide
these a big vector into chunks so that
it can be put onto different machines
right but actually it's not trivial
because we knew that between different
dimensions you can probably show that
there is a chance that the parameters
can be coupled
they may be even collinear if you
measure the same feature twice using
different devices and if that's
introduced then if you're
synchronization is not working right or
not synchronized at all and they are
still in computing parallel then you are
going to arraign to the statistic in
convincing problem and then the problem
can be divergent and the this is
actually the first hurdle rate will
overcome you know when you want to
divide the people develop a so-called a
model disability the problem in a
implementation and there has been a
number of work already there and the
first idea to come is to maybe have a
random partition betting on the chance
that the problem is sparse and the
coupling between dimensions may be weak
you can prove that you know the amount
of efficiency you can get all of it is
going to be a function of diameters of
the data basically how strong they are
couple together but this is a pretty
weak guarantee because in practice
you are almost always likely to run too
strong strongly coupling problems
especially in high dimensional settings
so that gives us opportunity for maybe a
system called design maybe we should
think about a system which can
dynamically schedule the task in the
structure whatever fashion by you know
examining basically the dependencies
among dimensions in a regression problem
or in other high dimensional problems
what that creates again yet another
problem which may be even harder because
the testing that I mentioned are that
the correlations between dimensions in a
very high dimension problem myself is a
very big problem it may be harder than
even the problem the regression problem
itself right so how do you you know
heuristic leo systematically solve that
well in there you have to leverage on
some other properties in machine
learning for example in machine learning
it's actually in high dimension
regression empirically people observe
that even you have a very high
dimensional problem not all dimensions
are equally important if you do the
iterative convergence operation maybe
every time a very small fraction of the
coefficients are actually changing and
many other things are not changing right
and this actually creates you accurately
maybe we should be focusing on the
scheduling on those a very very small
amount of a changing dimensions where
you know you are likely to feel a impact
and then if you can divide those
dimensions into different clusters in a
cleverly maybe you are going to have a
speed-up so in that there has been a
number of heuristic or formal ideas to
do priority scheduling and a block
scheduling the idea is to really you
know break apart
in a highly coupled you know bring
together Heydrich of dimensions to the
same machine and detect the you know
disable independent dimensions to
different machines and then a lot of
rain peril
and this algorithm or this approach is
called
the structure aware paralyzation SAP and
the system part is to basically make
this procedure automatic so that the
people hopefully in the future don't
have to do it by themselves so we have
to develop to a probing interface which
allowed people to specify the depen
and the schedule them you know without
touching the system details when these
are done the results are casually quite
interesting right you can see that by
comparing it and scheduled one and a
scheduled one you can see a dramatic
change of the convergence rate in the
experimental setting and also across
different models I think I even prove in
fact that this type of speed-up is
enjoying a convergence guarantee but
also with a rate now proportional to the
number of machines that you are going to
bring in of course this particular step
here and here requires you to divide the
data nicely here there is a little term
that tells you the cumulative in the
spectral diameter of the subset of data
on each machine if you can reduce them
effectively then this term will
disappear then you get the P fold
upgrade offer the speed then the second
problem that we are facing is that now
let your fuel you devalue a job and
hopefully they give you a nice
theoretical inside even guarantee on the
correctness but you still need to
communicate even though not so often so
how do you communicate typically we
don't ask this person we think you know
like Hadoop or like a single machine
communication shouldn't be seen by us
somehow it's automatically taken care of
let's say for the employee in this
particular you know now data parallel
problem which makes the problem set up a
bit in color I'm going to run maybe a
proximal gradient algorithm and from the
key updating step in here here and here
one kind easily identify maybe which one
to be the average rate form happening on
maybe a centralized to from and maybe
some other forms are in the
decentralized way freedom for the data
dependent computation of the gradient
could happen on each server machine or H
credit machine because they can work it
can be obtained from a success data that
aggregation of all these different sub
data set dependent gratings can be
happening on the center and at the
master for example by a summation and
then the projection to a particular
constraint space could also happen on a
server so these are you know a may be a
top-down hierarchical design but then
when you are putting this into a system
how basically in the
this particular step is going to be
dependent on the effectiveness of the
communication shall I wait for every
machine to give you this or should I
allow some in synchrony right in the
past people have been heavily relying on
this model which was actually a very
famous when proposed by valiant animal
Kong about 20 years ago called the bulk
synchronous parallel model PSP model
which means that you are going to set up
up areas after each iteration and when
communication happens no computing will
happen and when computing happens
happening no communication happen and
this actually can be proven leading to a
consistent and serializable results in
parallel setting and there has been a
lot of papers and that Hadoop spark with
ample orbit and this so called bridging
model between communication computing
but as I said bridging is very difficult
and expensive especially when you want
to do it iteratively for a few thousand
times in the machine language so how to
avoid that a couple of years ago Chris
Lee proposed the egg reason called the
hog world which basically says that
maybe the full clock is right you just
ignore the communication you know you
have multi-core machines you just divide
your job into different machines and
then let them all do their job and then
come back to your asynchronously and you
just update our ingre gate and whatever
you have at a pentacle time point right
and there are even theories behind that
to suggest that this is the right thing
to do because most of the high
dimensional problems are sparse if you
have a list of sort data and the start
of the data they may not touch in the
same dimension and different the course
therefore you are not likely to have a
condition right but it turns out that
this egg whiz isn't working very well in
the digital environment by the way they
work well on parallel environment there
is this ability between parallelism and
distribution by parallelism early
correspond to a multiple course on a
single machine the communication latency
between different cores are quite small
even though they are not zero but across
different machines in a cluster the
latency could be seconds or even longer
and that actually in the end effects
results in value can see we have a fear
in showing that the quality of the
solution depend on the mean and a
variance of the latency you know between
different
James so as a result you know maybe the
street food idea is to redesign the
system it okay to hopefully put a bunch
under live Nasir hi experience rather
than going the extreme or photo hosting
Crenn II are going to the other extreme
of a total asynchrony you want to stay
in the middle and the pound the amount
of is synchrony that each machine can
allow so that you communicate only when
this bound is exceeded this is called
the still synchronous parallel with a
bridging model and again you know the
system people are obliged to provide you
a nice proven interface so that this
thing can be easily usable as you use
Hadoop hopefully you don't have to write
your MPI code to directly control
machines and this architecture is not
known as the parameter server
architecture it provides you a simple
proven interface which are no different
from a single machine memory even though
it is the digital shared memory and in
practice people see that in fact it is
from our experiment we see that the
communication overhead drop dramatically
once you increase the amount of a
synchronous pound that you can allow
that's this I wouldn't converge and that
empirically we see that it is converging
in the environment faster and better in
across different algorithms and
theoretically we can also analyze this
behavior and we were able to prove that
you know the quality of the divergence
of the discrepancy and also the rate of
you know reducing to zero both depend on
you know the mean and the variance of
the a secretly order or the other of the
agency across different machines and as
a result you casually you know even to
an assistant to your needs to control
for example these particular two numbers
to get a faster convergence the same
idea also work on model parallelism
first inch of time I should skip that
but we have a similar proof showing you
that it doesn't affect the quality of
the consistency then I want to spend the
last part of the talk some even more
advanced but slightly more specialized
issues so there is this a very strange
question we recently ran into on what to
communicate this is a very strange
question
we are doing parallel computing on you
know machine learning model training and
we are supposed to communicate the
intermediate results of the model
training maybe the updates and
everything that's almost like there's no
question to ask there right you have you
have to communicate that and in fact
many of these models to be communicated
in the form of a matrix of numbers right
so you can call this a matrix
parameterize model this is actually a
pretty big family of models for them
deep neural network models is a matrix
you can even say regression model is a
one dimensional matrix although it is a
vector but in real case these kind of
matrices are often very big you know
across different models say here is a
model for multi class regression and for
distance metric learning topic model
your network we you know very often
trying to you know a problem which can
give you a half building or maybe a few
100 meeting number of parameters imagine
communicating this thing across the
Ethernet in a cluster right this is
horrible because it will choke your you
know your network almost in a second
therefore the full update is often not
practiced in a dictionary environment
just because it is too expensive you
know to even you know transmit the
intermediate updates across the system
so that actually caused us to think
about whether this is really the only
thing we can do in terms of a
distributed communication well it turns
out that the form of this update Delta W
often has a low rank structure
especially when you are squeezing down
the number of datas used to compute this
for example if you are computing data W
using one data point you can imagine the
rank should be one shouldn't be more
than one right because that's where the
data source come from in fact you can
always establish that the Delta can be
expressed in the form of an ultra
product of two vectors one is the data
dependent the other is a probably in the
parameter dependent and then it is the
assemblage from these two pre updates
that leads to this a very you know heavy
duty fool
update of a matrix what are you for we
focus on communicating the pre updates
instead of the updates that potentially
gives you a lighter communication
overhead so this is the idea called
sufficient vectors which we explored in
the past few months and I'm going to
talk about a little bit by the readouts
there are some difficulties in
establishing equivalence between these
two because for the full updates it is
very naturally following the natural
computational architecture which is like
a master/slave architecture because you
can easily aggregate all these you know
in the update matrixes from different
clients into here by a simple summation
therefore you can distribute them in a
very straightforward fashion the pre
updates actually cannot be easily
aggregated because once you aggregate
all these sub pre updates you start to
lose the low ranking is they stop being
a auto product actors they become a
matrix therefore you are going to be
running into the very expensive thing
therefore you have to basically transmit
to the supreme dates one data at a time
which is a little bit expensive but on
the other hand nowadays people routinely
use fantastic algorithms or mini-batch
equations in which every update is
actually using a small amount of data
therefore you could imagine that in
practice the implementation of a
stochastic with integration could
benefit from this a new communication
protocol so and the good thing about the
discrimination Pro is that it has a much
smaller storage trace because you don't
have to store the matrix at all you can
just sort the vector form and also maybe
the size of the batch of that and this
storage is also is not elastic you don't
have to pre allocate the whole thing it
really could be in the requested round
needs you know in your local machines
there is also a communication benefit
which I'm going to measure in a second
but just to give you you know a
empirical evidence we do see that across
the algorithm different models like I
think there's a thesis metric learning
multitask learning I may be a topic
model you actually see Universal kind of
improvements in terms of the convergence
rate and the way actually have evidence
showing that the
communications you know between the full
matrix and the sufficient vectors even
though you have to broadcast it to Inga
in a data dependent fashion is much
reduced so I want to say a few words
about how to do the broadcast right so
here I stopped short of giving you the
guarantee and whether what I did just
now is radically you know consistent or
safe but to discuss that we need to
basically understand the last bit where
is which is how this message should be
communicated remember that web very
especially machinery people are very
much used to this particular
architecture which is the server worker
or the master slave architecture node
from the server Hadoop and spark you
know all of this type of architecture
meaning that you have a centralized
place to aggregate all the messages you
have maybe unbounded number of slaves to
do the partial work and then the thing
to be communicated are those work that
needs to be done for example the full
matrix of the parameter and also the
full matrix of the parameter updates by
the way these directions need to be sent
these messages need to be sent in both
direction because for each worker to
compute the proper updates then you do
have the latest possible version of the
flow parameters itself therefore they
have to have this message that in the
decentralize the fashion which is
actually popular in our cell phone
network and other into a computational
infrastructure
the idea is to maybe only send to this
Delta the pre updates but again as I
said prick updates is as big as the full
updates if you don't do any reduction
therefore how can we actually change the
idea a bit right so here I have some
comparison between the two architecture
which I'm asleep but I want to point out
that sending this a sufficient factor is
requiring you to switch away from the
master slave architecture to the p2p
architecture because as I said the pre
updates cannot be you know aggregated
you know before they sent before they
will communicate it
so that leads us to this a peer-to-peer
communication meaning that every machine
has to broadcast its pre updates which
are the two low dimensional vectors into
all the other machines so that the post
updates can be computed ih machine
locally from this low rank you know pre
updates and that probably will cause you
to worry some because well that means I
need to have a square on the P Square
number of messages in the whole network
because you know it is it is a broadcast
scheme and if my network is very big
then that's going to have you another
factor of the quadratic factor of the
capacity well in theory that's the case
but it turns out that the we have some
tricks to reduce this particular
protocol again from a quadratic
complexity to linear capacity in term in
terms of the size of the network one of
these idea is called the partial
broadcast so imagine that this is a
machine algorithm which is the not to
pass the message only one time to the
rest of network iteratively it will
basically keep sending to the neighbors
and you imagine that even if a broadcast
message to two neighbors in the next
generation that message what we relate
to the next neighbors in our next
iteration so somehow there is this
effect of information relay in the
network even if you just broadcast that
your message partially to a subset of
neighbors so this idea can be formalized
and can be analyzed but the effect is
that they are going to generate a
computational communication complexity
which is only linear to the size of
network and with a constant which is
roughly giving you the size of the
neighborhood you have the broadcast
which can be very small and secondly you
can also select the waling of the
message by doing the so-called
sufficient effect your selection you
don't have to transmit all sufficient
factors in fact after you compute all
these pre updates empirically especially
enlarge the setting many of the updates
are redundant you can pre screen those
redundancy using sound formula and then
take out only those sufficient factors
which are less redundant Anacin
out so by these two folds of tricks you
actually could dramatically reduce also
the transfer communication overhead
that's the number and the size the
number of messages basically you know in
the network so previously I talked about
the size of message and now it is the
number of the messages and when you put
these two ideas together you are going
to enjoy this again across different
algorithms distance metric learning
multi master equation and topic model
you are going to see you know a pretty
strong you know improvement in terms of
the speed of convergence you know across
different in here we compare to quite a
few different iPad where this is not a
topic on it is that deep neural network
and implemented using popular
alternatives versus ours you can see you
know the improvement is seeing across
different models and also this idea is
scaling very well to the size of the
cluster when you add more and more
machines you are likely to see you know
a close for linear increase of the power
of the ability in handling larger
problems and the ways the assumption of
sufficient factor broadcast and under
posed in a full communication broadcast
and a partial broadcast we can establish
the consistency results which I'm not
going to spell out in detail but the
take-home message is that you are going
to you know you know converge to the
solution which is no different from
sending out the full update matrix to
every neighbor in a distributed network
so that's again you know another
advantage you know in exploring system
and equus mokou design to get a faster
solution across different type of
evidence and this idea actually could
also coexist with some other ideas so
for them what I talked first about the
prompt to survive year which is a
centralized communication protocol I
also talked about the sufficient factor
broadcast which is a peer-to-peer decent
trust protocol these two things doesn't
have to be excluding each other in fact
they could coexist
and and then communicate the amount of
model parameters dependent on you know
the needs and also the circunstances for
example in a typical what I want to
claim that I'm not a fan of deep neural
network per se but this is a thing that
has been used in many companies so we
you know as a research I have to at
least address the engineering problems
how to get them fast right so here we
observe the following interesting
behavior if you look at this whole deep
neural network multiple layers the size
of the parameters actually is a not
uniform right in the you know I think in
the later part I think this is the early
part of the network you have very high
dimensional matrix because you are
defining low-level features in at the
pixel level right but in the higher
level network part you are going to work
with a high level features which are
much more lower dimensional therefore
the number of parameters to be
communicated appear to be less therefore
you know these two type of parameters
could enjoy maybe two different
communication protocol this one may
benefit from a sufficient factor
broadcast and that part could benefit
from a parameter server centralized
communication and that's actually what
we did and after you do this you are
going to see now a huge improvement
again over the scalability of you know
deep neural network models that is
popular out there example here we have
deep neural network models implemented
in cafe in tensorflow I think the name
of that work is called the VG g18 or
something I think it's one of the
winners of the imagenet competition
which makes the mirror popular the thing
I want to say here is that waited an
infant this model these models are
included by others using pencil flow and
using cafe way basic just provide a new
low level communication layer for their
messages to be communicated across
machines right so originally it was a
single machine plantation and now we
have a disagreement ation they also have
their own discrimination which in our
opinion is very lousy and we compare you
can see that this is the
performance of you know different
implementations across more and more
number of machines and you can see that
in a terrible scenario in this
particular case the pencil flow model
start to go worse when you add more
machines which is not accurate
surprising because if you have a to
bigger model and you add more machines
and force them to communicate across
machines they choke the network and emit
convergence even worse you will see some
other graph later where the tensorflow
digital version does improve but not as
much as what we did in here so here
again I want to make sure that all these
curves are measured over convergence
time not over the throughput which in my
opinion is a more accurate and a
meaningful measurement of the quality of
computing so here I'll give you just a
few more comparisons now it is not just
one peep in your network as you see in
the previous slides we have a few other
deep neural networks which are basically
image and winners over the past several
years and they range in terms of the
architecture and also in terms of the
number of parameters there are some
smaller models which has a roughly let's
say 60 million parameters which are you
know not too big and therefore when you
add more machines the network is still
able to handle the communication
therefore you see these you know
improvements with more and more
resources even using the native
tensorflow distributed version but when
you have a larger model which has like a
100 or 200 million parameters ok the
whole thing start to to to to to to go
down and then you can see this a
terrible degradation of the disputed
results but instead you know in our
protocol where the s VB and also the the
prominent server are all brought to bear
to reduce the communication we do see
still a linear upgrades of the
performance of the convergence rate this
is a similar solution for a different
implementation of the same network in
cafe and the still you know I think we
do quite well you know using the product
cause I just mentioned so that brings to
the end of my talk I just want push
share with you our experiences in a
jointly considering algorithmic
innovation and also system communication
and hopefully do this iteratively to
enable a co-designed solution and these
are the points I've visited in the talk
but I think there are more questions
than answers nowadays you know in the
scalable and you know universally
mountable machine learning programs and
different architectures so I do want to
bring attention to the etc theory
community to look into these type of
problems which does always have this
part basically we are going to have a an
ideal hardware infrastructure system
which factors into the very performance
of the computing and how to you know
analyze that and how to mitigate their
negative effects is I think to be a very
interesting problem so again I didn't
really touch all the issues there are
many other issues I don't have time to
cover but if you are interested I'd be
very happy to take them offline to
discuss more at the end you know the
goal of the project happening at CMU and
also at my startup is really to turn
this a very you know intimidating you
know picture of generating machine
learning and AI solutions into something
that is a more standardized and more
encapsulated so that you can really
intimately and carefully you know
consider many different assistance every
snake and infrastructure choices but of
course when you are done with this you
know you're hopefully you know can you
know offer better performance in all
these different technical dimensions but
to the users I have to emphasize and
many of the users like to see machinery
like this they really want to meddle
mess up with the inner details of the
system not even programming their own
equation they may just want to deploy
their solutions on top of their hardware
and then letting the middle layer to be
taken care of by some providers and as I
think what our research is trying to
lead a word ok that's the end of my
talks thank you
[Applause]